michel scarbonchi et bonjour et merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors on le voit déconfinement à degrés
divers avec des restrictions de
déplacement des contrôles renforcés
un tour de vis européen en ordre
dispersé c'est révélateur de la
confusion qui règne en ce moment au sein
des pays de l'ue ne dirais pas que c'est
la confusion c'est que vous savez que
l'union européenne n'a pas de compétence
en matière de santé et que face à la
pandémie que nous subissons depuis
maintenant plus d'un an elle a pris
cette responsabilité d'organiser une
agence sanitaire d'acheter 2 et de
répartir des doses avec toutes les
difficultés que nous connaissons il fait
de la non du non respect des contrats
signés par certains producteurs dans
lost zeneca mais les pays les pays ont
leur souveraineté
1 il ya l'union européenne et puis lé
pays aussi qui chacun en fonction de ce
qu'il se passe sur leur territoire
adoptent des stratégies sanitaires plus
ou moins approprié nous faisons face à
une troisième vague dans toute l'europe
vous avez des pays qui confirme
complètement des pays qui les confine et
des pays qui comme la france confinement
vous permettant de rester à l'extérieur
voilà où nous en sommes il est évident
qu'il n'y a pas la même politique pour
tous les pays
la seule chose qui est constante pour
c'est le fait que l'union européenne a
reçu au premier trimestre 107 millions
de doses pour les répartir sur les 27
pays membres
elle devait en recevoir 200 millions
elle ne l'a pas eu
elle va avoir trois cent soixante
millions de doses au deuxième trimestre
et est la mi juillet nous avons
l'assurance que les 450 millions
d'habitants de l'europe dans tout cas
des 27 pays membres de l'union
européenne ont une immunité collective
voilà où nous en sommes voilà la réalité
justement en termes de vaccination c'est
un petit peu chaotique 1 puisque on l'a
vu certains pays ont avancé grâce à
l'arrivée de vaccins sans même attendre
le feu vert des autorités sanitaires
européennes dont d'autres sont à la
traîne est ce que finalement l'union
européenne a raté le coche puisque on
sait que l'om est ça
également critiqué cette lenteur je cite
inacceptable de la vaccination sur le
continent oui mais écoutez l'om mais
c'est bien gentil que l' oms commence
pas corriger ses propres erreurs depuis
le début de la pandémie après donnera
des leçons aux états et à l'union
européenne
il ne faut oublier une chose l'union
européenne a signé des contrats avec des
entreprises avec des laboratoires
certains laboratoires n'ont pas respecté
les engagements pris de des doses qu'il
devait fournir à l'union européenne
face à cela l'union européenne sur une
répartition au prorata des populations
des états membres or vous avez des états
qui n'ont pas voulu prendre le vaccin de
pfizer et donc préféré prendre le vaccin
à sera zeneca parce qu'ils étaient moins
chers et donc ces pays là comme
l'autriche la slovénie est là et la
tchéquie se sont retrouvés en difficulté
de vaccination à cause de cela c'est
leur faute c'est pas la faute de l'union
européenne c'est eux qu'on fait ses
choix
c'est pour ça que l'union européenne
dans sa réunion du 25 mars a décidé de
répartir 3 millions de doses versé des
pays comme la bulgarie la croatie la
slovaquie la lettonie et l'estonie qui
avait des difficultés
d'approvisionnement
non il ne faut pas où c'est jean louis
bourlanges l'ancien eurodéputé qui avait
eu cette formule il avait dit que ont
fait de l'union européenne le bouc
émissaire de nos échecs nationaux en
matière sanitaire
voilà ce sont les états qui ont fait des
fautes qui ont commis des erreurs
ils se sont trompés et c'est un peu
normal face à une pandémie aussi
importante à nous sommes en train de
vivre un tchernobyl à la puissance 10
faut pas l'oublier
la haye les enseignes endémie pareil
imaginez bien que les états en fonction
de leurs seins de leurs systèmes
sanitaires ont réagi plus ou moins bien
alors certains maintenant à l'extrême
gauche à l'extrême droite en europe
voudrait faire croire que c'est la faute
de l'europe elle est le bouc émissaire
de tous nos problèmes
c'est faux d'ailleurs les mêmes qui
disent cela sont ceux qui ne voudraient
pas que l'union européenne existe donc
une contradiction la fondamentale pour
revenir à ces mesures
sanitaires qui ont été décidées par
plusieurs pays l'italie l'espagne
l'allemagne notamment aux frontières
on voit que là aussi c'est une mesure
qui est pas toujours bien accepté
est ce que aujourd'hui faudrait
généraliser se diriger justement vers
une fermeture des frontières coordonnée
au niveau européen
oui je suis d'accord il faudrait
coordonner le transfert des populations
au niveau européen
nous savons tous que nous pouvons sortir
de cette crise que par une vaccination
complète des populations des états
membres nous pourrons voyager quand nous
aurons l'immunité collective
pour cela il faut qu'au moins les trois
quarts des 450 millions d'habitants de
l'union européenne soient vaccinés c'est
pour ça que là la vraie course contre la
montre actuellement c'est la vaccination
nous sommes certains qu'à partir du mois
de mai je vous disais un à partir du
mois de la mi juillet nous aurons cette
immunité collective
en attendant il faut donc éviter que des
gens qui ne sont pas vaccinés se rendent
dans des pays en cours de vaccination
c'est le bon sens des goussets et la
population européenne est le plus
l'habitude en conflit depuis 70 ans et
de plus habitué aux graves crises depuis
70 ans et donc les gens vivent dans le
confronte dans la tranquillité etc n'ont
pas le sens des responsabilités
qu'avaient les générations précédentes
c'est ça le mâle européen il est là elle
les gens ont leur confort leur habitude
ils veulent pas du tout s'en priver bah
oui quand on est en période de crise et
de pandémie on se prive d'un certain
nombre de choses parce que c'est le bon
sens tout simplement c'est se protéger
soi-même pour protéger les autres il
faut que les roses européenne comprenne
cela parce que nous allons vivre avec
des pandémies pendant des dizaines
d'années
merci beaucoup à michel scarbonchi
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes ancien député
européen